[Music]
someone tell me why there's a
three-second teaser for the trailer
right before the trailer I mean I
already clicked on the video I'm clearly
going to watch the trailer why are you
prolonging it anyways welcome back to
things you missed this time I'll be
looking at the Slender Man trailer it
looks like a lot of the suspense will
come from the question of what lies in
the abyss is that just a group of skinny
trees in the distance or is something
staring back at me
I wanted to analyze these images and
find out but unfortunately it seems that
there's only this one siting as far as I
can tell it looks to me like the movie
will be centered around these three
girls which does make me wonder if
they'll incorporate elements of the
real-life Slender Man stabbing in 2014
which was a story about two mentally
insane girls who tried to kill their
friend and claim that Slender Man made
them do it we also see this mobile thing
which contains three girls and a bunch
of these other figures it doesn't look
like they'll turn against each other in
this movie but the idea of him getting
in kids heads and making them do stuff
seems to be supported by the dialogue it
would seem that this movie is based more
off that news story than the traditional
creepypasta lore the original image from
something awful forums which was the
basis for Slenderman as a character
would have been a great easter egg to
put here but it looks like they're just
taking in a different direction with
this one the inclusion of these
deviantART looking ass Slenderman
fangirl hentai drawings instead is a
clear indicator that this film is going
more towards a portrayal of the real
world affective slenderman's takeover
rather than the lore based one possibly
response to the critical failure of the
Marble Hornets movie there also seems to
be something about stabbing out eyes in
this movie Slenderman has no face so he
may be trying to do the same
his victims we see multiple shots of
eyes being stabbed and several pictures
in the wall include eyes and eye
injuries this character's eyes are
different colors and I hope you like
black licorice this looks like a shot
out of a happening and when we finally
see Slenderman if you slow it down it
looks like he could be made out of the
same yarn material as those figures on
the mobile you may or may not have
caught this image of Slenderman in front
of the tree flash on the screen for just
a second at the end of the trailer if
you were unimpressed by this trailer let
me know by giving this video a like I
just wanted to talk about it because
Slenderman is an important part of what
made YouTube horror what it is today so
if you're interested in creepy stuff
online then you're gonna want to go
ahead and subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week bring
that death bell for notifications buy
this mug and I'll see you in the next
one
assuming we both survive